es el cohete más potente que la nasa ha
construido el equivalente moderno al
saturno 5 que envió a humanos a la luna
durante la era del apolo el nuevo
sistema de lanzamiento está en cabo
cañaveral listo para seguir sus pasos a
finales de agosto llegará a la luna
llevando tres maniquíes de prueba y los
astronautas de la nasa en la tierra
estarán observando de cerca
la parte más importante de toda esta
misión es asegurarse de que cuando esta
cápsula golpee la tierra entra en la
atmósfera a 11 km por segundo para su
audiencia europea que el escudo aguante
y cuando tengamos ese punto de prueba
entonces estaremos listos para poner a
personas en el vehículo
será el primer vuelo de la misión
artemis de la nasa cuyo objetivo es
enviar a seres humanos a la órbita lunar
en 2024 con un aterrizaje lunar en 2025
los astronautas ya se están aquí matando
y los científicos están maravillados con
el regreso de los viajes lunares
de vez en cuando me doy cuenta que esto
es lo que realmente voy a hacer he visto
el apolo 13 en televisión y el cine y
voy a hacer el hombre que esté ahí
cuando encendamos los motores para dar
la vuelta a la luna eso es realmente
increíble
la misión artemis uno que lleva el
nombre de la hermana del dios mitológico
apolo está programada para ser más
diversa la nasa se propone lograr una
serie de primicias llevar a la primera
mujer y la primera persona afro a la
luna y finalmente poner un pie en marte